carnegie mellon
me too I guess realized my full
potential while I was here I was
studying I
but I was also you know taking business
classes taking writing classes the
biggest stumbling block to an artist
trying to make themselves into a
professional type of professional career
is the fact that it they don't
understand the business that is within
their art whether it be acting or art or
dance or whatever the case is and you
know you can be a great artist but have
poor business skills and never make it
no collaborating as a nature of the art
but it's also the nature of the business
the more you know the more you're able
to do as an actor your job is to
recreate you know life truthfully
experiences truthfully and the more
experience that you have the better
you'll be at that my experience at
carnegie solidified my certainty that
this is what i meant to do with my life
so I feel like that's the biggest way
that it shaped all of my successes or
all of my experiences you know I just
feel like drawing on that sort of
certitude and that belief in myself when
nobody else believed in me was something
that I could definitely trace back to
Barbara Mackenzie would and and and my
first semester of freshman acting with
her we just remember her telling me to
trust myself you know and that that was
a lesson that never left me you know and
never ever left me